hey everyone welcome back to the
GameSpot stage here at e3 2017 joining
Callie and myself is Pete Hines who you
might recognize from that this Fez does
III press-conference Pete thank you so
much joining us solutely thanks for
having me and we had to talk about the
evil within you another little surprise
you guys just sort of dropped into press
conference I mean very exciting I mean
where do we start up how where is the
game gonna drop us off so it picks up a
little bit after the events of the first
evil within where Sebastian's life has
basically gone to hell nobody really
believes his account of what happened at
the asylum he's essentially lost his
family his his daughter died his he and
his wife are splits he's an alcoholic
he's basically hit the very bottom of
the barrel and that's where we find him
at the outset of evil within two if he
played the first evil within remember
his partner Kidman Kidman comes back and
finds him and says he thought your
daughter was dead she's not mobius has
her they're using her and you need to go
in and get her and bring her out and
that's where the evil within to starts
it's a redemption story about a father
trying to get the daughter he thought
was dead back and hopefully pieces life
back together mmm so what I loved about
the first game is that not only I mean
it was changing Mikami it was the master
of horror games kind of going back to
where you just burst but it had this
story that had so many layers of
creepiness and just psychological
torment is that yeah for sure I mean
it's it's definitely a game that keeps
the player off balance I think it's true
for a lot of games but certainly for a
survival horror that you sort of have to
balance the the intensity of whether
it's jump scares or frightening combat
or whatever that if you just do that
non-stop that the player essentially
becomes desensitized to it because it's
just all the time it's kind of fatiguing
so you have to sort of balance that that
intensity with with exploration and a
little bit of downtime to allow the
player to catch their breath and I think
that's one of the things that Shinji and
his team are doing a little bit more of
this time around is more more sections
that have exploration options side
quests things that you can do to maybe
get some more resources to help better
prepare you for the next
area as opposed to just more of a a to B
B to C linear path which you can still
do like if you just kind of want to go
through and play the main quest you
still can but there's lots more side
quests and areas to explore and as a
result sort of varying the the intensity
and and how that impacts the player
visually from an audio standpoint you
know as you as you will know survival
horror games really rely heavily on
sound design and using science of sound
design and sound effects to to create
tension and and drama even when nothing
is actually happening so finding the
right mix of all those things is you
know one of the things we've tried to
improve on even more and evil with into
it so it's gonna its gingiva call me
directing this one yeah I mean he's it's
his studio and his hands are still all
over it so when it you talk about that
pacing or their certain moments or or
amplifying a particular area or maybe
ratcheting things down a little bit
because he you know he wants the player
to have a little bit of beat or to do
something else that you know that's what
shinji is is best at so yeah he's still
the head of this project overall but you
know he's been working with other people
on the team to maybe step up and take
larger roles in different parts of the
game as he continues to try and grow his
team yeah cuz I remember reading an
interview with him where he said that he
thought that game directors over the age
of 40 were given like all the all the
best games they were given the most
opportunities and he felt that younger
developers and designers weren't
necessarily given those opportunities I
think he still believes that and I think
he's tried to to sort of take that into
account as the evil within too has
progressed in terms of giving people the
opportunity to be more of a lead where
he's not directly telling folks know
we're gonna do it like this know this
enemies gonna look like this know this
level is gonna look like this but at the
same time all of that stuff still rolls
up to somebody and so shinji still you
know has been involved has you know kind
of given his feedback and and kind of
tweaked and tuned things and talking to
the team as we've gone through and will
continue to all the way through launch
aside from the sidequest structure you
mentioned there
anything else that's like a big
departure from the first game the fans
can expect to see yeah I don't know if
it's a departure but definitely an area
that we wanted to focus on more was that
idea of character and story which isn't
to say that even within didn't have one
but I think they really wanted to
emphasize that as a point of strength
this time around both with Sebastian as
a character and if you played the evil
within it's probably not out of bounds
to say he's kind of an a-hole very
likeable character not really somebody
that the player necessarily sort of you
know he's no Nathan Drake he's not this
sort of easily associate character to
that you that you play as there's a
little bit of a disconnect there and so
I think this time around with Sebastian
in this quest to find his daughter and
sort of humanizing him a lot you know
last time he was a detective and he was
detecting he was trying to figure out
what was going on this time it's very
different it's about finding his
daughter it's a very personal story and
seeing him sort of at his very lowest
point and following his journey and
guiding him through his journey for for
redemption
I think is a better overall sort of
narrative and connection with the player
and then what the team is done with even
some of the enemies you know in the
trailer and what we showed at the
Showcase we showed a little bit of
Stephano who is this sort of like
psychotic murderer slash artist he's
he's interested in in the beauty and art
of death he's the guy that you see with
the knife killed the soldier who stays
in this sort of arced position with the
rose petals coming out of him so he he's
very sort of obsessed with the beauty of
death and he has this sort of sidekick
creature thing called obscura who's like
a living camera that takes pictures of
all of this and so sort of developing
those into more interesting
personalities and characters in and of
themselves as well as some of the
characters you'll meet as you're
exploring around the world I think gives
you a much better sense of place where
we didn't have as much of that in the
evil within the the player choice and I
think the last one would be just sort of
be the world warping aspect that as
you're playing through it's not just
will I walk into this room and then I
turned around and there used to be a
door there now there's a wall like
it's more about big spaces that are kind
of being warped and changed in this sort
of virtual world that stem is that that
would the player will experience and
kind of explore and will affect their
journey through the game go ahead to the
first game obviously he goes to the
asylum and he's warped around a bunch of
really kind of psychology quite scary
events and sees a lot of incredible
monsters in the second game what what is
the setting so we're not in the asylum
anymore we're kind of correct so the
basic set up for the evil within is
there's a corporation called Mobius and
Mobius has this idea that they can take
and connect the consciousness of this is
the my stupid interpretation probably
way more complex and on point but it's
sort of connecting the consciousness of
people to create like a new world a new
reality and what's happened in the evil
within to is Mobius took your daughter
who you thought was dead and used her as
the sort of clean slate as the Center
for stem to create a new world and
that's where you get sent to find her so
it's it's a virtual world that you sort
of go into to find her that's been
created it's sort of powered by your by
your daughter and that's where you go
but as you're playing through it it's
sort of changing and evolving and stuff
is is happening to it so it's not like I
went to this asylum and there was the
serial killer and then sort of things
went down a rabbit hole you're sort of
jumping immediately into this other
world which is where she is somewhere to
be found and and kind of powering all
this so she's like the the kind of host
I guess you're facing yes exactly she's
probably a better word yes so but
imagine like as a child she would have a
very sort of pure look at the world yeah
but there must be these forces that are
manipulating her and what's going on
there and how all of that sort of gets
so corrupted and distorted and awful is
part of what you part of what you find
out as you as you play the game the
Flies very interested buzzing by yeah
that's part of the story that unravels
like well like just on its face value
why does that mean that you're in this
horrible distorted
what's happened and and how it's gotten
to that point is part of the story as
Sebastian's going through to try and
find his daughter and what that mean
that the the like monsters and enemies
you encounter are fabrications of
somebody's mind basically like like the
the the things that you see are almost
at least some of the things you see are
almost manifestations of corrupted ideas
or awful things or or whatever terrible
memories that have manifested themselves
into creatures or monsters or or
whatever it is you'll see here like even
in this trailer where this sort of ooze
is grabbing him that's a reoccurring
theme in the world the stuff that kind
of infects and corrupts everything
around it affects some of the monsters
and creatures and how they manifest
themselves it has some gameplay
implications so it's a constantly sort
of changing evolving keep the player
off-balance as they're playing through
through the game in terms of where am i
and what am i doing and what's going on
and and where do I go next and what do I
do it's been an incredible year for
Japanese games I mean like near Neo
Resident Evil 7 and now looking ahead to
the evil within - how do you think that
like I mean what what is it bring to
Bethesda sort of slative Games is to
have this kind of tentpole horror finder
well I mean I've been at Bethesda almost
18 years I feel fairly confident saying
we're not really known for survival
horror so it's not like we have this
long legacy of all of the survival
horror franchises and this is another
one but I think what we do share with
tango is this idea of sort of a really
good sense of place we like working with
Studios that have a real passion and
expertise which clearly shinji and his
team do and sort of working with them to
allow them to come up with and create
something even if it's not necessarily
what we're known for known for from a
genre standpoint it does fit kind of our
ideals of you know trying to do
something different survival horror was
kind of heading in this one direction
where it was a lot more of kind of
almost an arsenal and mowing things down
and lots of ammo and the evil within
kind of zigged when everybody else died
and said no we're gonna go with scarcity
of resources and trying really hard to
stay alive and running away maybe being
your best option a lot of the time
or giving the player some choice in
terms of how they're going to handle a
situation I think we share those kind of
design sensibilities with them but you
know it's bringing a very unique
perspective to our lineup one that you
know you wouldn't necessarily think of
an it'd or arcane as being folks that
would do survive ahora but Shinji Mikami
and tango like what that makes total
sense because that's what they know and
that's kind of where he where he started
in this industry so it was a good fit
for us and and we're pretty excited
about what's coming with the evil within
- mm-hmm well you stole my question
sorry I was gonna specifically ask about
the the survival horror face because we
got Resident Evil we got outlast - but
you pretty much answered well one of the
things that we've talked about you know
I get asked is like well I guess if I'm
not into survival horror like this isn't
really for me and look if you if you
don't like being scared well then you
definitely shouldn't play this because
it's a scary game but it's not like it's
not like blood-borne right it's not just
like awful it's not a Saw movie where
there's just blood and dismemberment all
the time and I think because it's got
some really compelling action and a
character and story that are gonna be
really engaging that even if you're not
predisposed to survive a horror this
might be a thing you end up looking at I
mean visually I think it looks really
good it does have elements of sort of
action-adventure games that I think
folks will take - and you know there was
a certain amount of that we saw from the
evil within where folks tried it and
maybe we didn't quite pay off as much on
things like story but I think this time
around because it's more of an emphasis
but you know you don't have to love
survival horror or else you won't like
this game though you do have to be
willing to be scared because that is
definitely going to happen ok so you're
not going for blood point but what I
find is that the character the creature
design in particular is kind of the
thing that not discussed but like that's
the thing that gets to me
no disgust is a pretty good actually
yeah like the very first one that you
see I'm thinking yeah the very first one
that you see is just absolutely
disgusting and horrify just on its own
just like nightmarish I'm gonna wake up
sweating at 3 in the morning thinking of
that thing chasing me
it doesn't even have to do anything to
you it's just the sort of the appearance
of
that is disturbing enough on its own and
then of course like well most of the
time they are trying to kill you and you
do have to deal with them and then it
becomes just that much more intense and
scary but yeah they are off-putting and
and unsettling as is the world and again
that you know as we talked about the
sound design really plays into that if
you have something that's really
unsightly that's one thing but then when
it emits like god-awful shrieks and
screams it makes it like that much worse
yeah right so I think finding the the
balance of those things is where the fun
comes from designing games like this and
giving the player something that you
know they're not ready for or they
certainly didn't expect have you ever
seen a creature design come through for
evolve in tune and kind of thought dude
it's like where did you get that idea oh
yeah like all of them like pretty much
pretty much all of them there's never
anything that the that team comes up
with where you're like oh that seems
really normal like a normal balance sane
person would come up with that on their
own all like like every team meeting
that we have or they like put up
character sketches and designs you're
like what is wrong with you guys like
what is coming up with this do you guys
need a hug like what is going on over
there who hurts you
yeah it's unsettling but you know when
you play it when you see it in the game
you're like yeah that's pretty scary it
works for our survival horror game
that's pretty horrific mmhmm yeah I mean
I guess to bounce off all that off of
that the trailer kind of has a mix of
there's like sort of something that
looks a little grotesque a lot of it is
very like real and you know unsettling
in different ways you say that there's
more of that that second kind of like
you know like not uncanny valley but
just something that's just slightly off
versus the more grotesque I would say
there's a healthy amount I don't know if
I've played enough because it's sort of
changing as you going through but
there's there's a healthy mix of both I
don't know whether it's 40 40 20 or
whatever but yeah there's definitely the
like that that's just horrifying and and
then they just like like I'm not I'm
like nothing jumped out at me but I'm
really put off and unsettled right now
like walking down a hallway and
Stefano's mansion where he's just got
all these pictures of like eyeballs or
like a ballerinas foot and it just has
this like horrible
actually the ankle and you're like it's
not it's not like you can see all the
stuff inside but it's just like it's
really creepy and like why would anybody
put a picture up like that it's that
kind of stuff yeah that sort of again to
the point of you can really decide
sensitize a player very quickly
especially in a game like this that you
know this is not a short six seven eight
hour game this is a pretty long
experience and if you go right for and
stay with bloody gross horror like by
our five you're just kind of done right
like what else am I going to show you
that's worse like right it's all been
disgusting so our six is like yeah
whatever like more disgusting stuff
pretty disgusting you have to mix in
enough of that stuff that that isn't
actually horrific but it's just like
there's when you look at it and you guys
know what they like you see any juice
like that that's just wrong it's not
gross and it's not awful and it doesn't
make me sick but like that's just not
okay yeah there's enough stuff that's
just not okay that really helps sort of
the player along in those moments where
it's not intense combat or jump scares
or whatever you're running for your life
that that continues to keep that just
that edge of tension all along that you
never really feel sort of safe or calm
even when nothing's happening
well we are very familiar with that
because we're staying one of the most
haunted hotels in Los Angeles as well
yeah I mean she and I are fine but we
like that spooky stuff but yeah but
unsettling hallways that don't feel like
they were designed quite right yeah yes
like that yeah when you see it you know
it yeah and it and it definitely has
that feeling in here that you know and
it's part of what makes gaming fun I
mean in this particular case like you're
watching a movie and it's a it's a
horror movie you're like you're
screaming at the screen like don't go in
that room like what are you doing run
away like well in the evil within like
there's a lot of times where you can
decide nope not walking down that
hallway seems like a terrible idea I'm
gonna go this way or I'm you know I'm
gonna approach this a different way to
try and improve my chances of not dying
badly here right had your bedside yeah I
think I can either go in this creepy
hallway or hope nothing's gonna kill me
this way exactly okay thank you so much
for joining us I remind us again when
the evil within two is coming out
on Friday the 13th of October so not to
not too far away almost exactly five
months right well four months away yeah
we're right there whoo that was kind of
spooky um yeah be out October 13th
Friday 13th for Xbox one and ps4 and PC
wonderful well thank you so much for
joining us for all the all the latest
all the biggest games here from e3 2017
make sure you keep your eyes peeled to
GameSpot calm